so welcome to the session on um making
dashboards with quto I am sort of in a
state of mind of hoping for snow soon so
I have named this talk dashing through
the snow or sharing your data in a quto
dashboard so my name is Mina chitin
randelle I am a professor at Duke
University and also a developer educator
at pit uh paa is a company that uh sort
of sponsors the development of quto the
open source product so I will start by
introducing you to CTO a little bit and
then we're going to dive right into
making dashboards with Corto so let's go
ahead and get started here so what is
Corto Corto is an open- Source
scientific and Technical publishing
system and it builds on standard
markdown with features that are
essential for scientific communication
so your Pros is written in markdown and
render with pandoc um computational
cells are um executed with uh Jupiter
kernels and the nice thing with Corto is
that you can get dozens of output
formats so we're going to be talking
about dashboards today but I'll do uh
very brief sort of like demos of
creating an HTML file plain HTML file or
a presentation or PDF so on and so forth
and you can have uh specialized project
types so you can use quto to create a
standalone PDF document or you can use
it to write a Web
book so with c so you can basically
weave together narrative and code to
produce elegantly formatted output as
documents web pages blog posts books and
more and CTO Is Not the Only Solution
out there that sort of gets you this but
some of my favorite things about CTO is
that there's a consistent implementation
of what I find to be attractive and
handy features across outputs for
example the way you uh create tab sets
in um a presentation or a book is
exactly the same code folding is
available throughout I am an educator I
oftentimes am teaching code and that's
one of the most handy things tools that
I have to sort of like Hideway code from
learners for a brief moment to get them
to think about things and then give them
an opportunity to unfold it to see the
answers for example um as well as syntax
highlighting so these are implemented in
exactly the same way across different
output formats in addition quto has
native multilingual support for python
Julia and observable uh and more via the
Jupiter engine and also uh for our via
the Knitter
engine and importantly CTO comes out of
the box with defaults that meet
accessibility guidelines as well as
features that enable sort of good
practices for producing accessible
documents one of my favorite things is
that it is um you have an easy way for
example of writing alternative text for
any figures that you include in a CTO
document whether that is an image that
you're embedding in a document as a PNG
file or a figure that you're generating
computationally for example so how does
it work um well with quto we have the
computations uh happen with the Jupiter
engine or Knitter or observable JS um
the markdown is handled by uh and then
out comes a markdown plain text markdown
document that that then pan processes
with many enhancements that CTO adds on
top of that and you can get a variety of
outputs as I said um at the end so here
for example is a very sort of like um
vanilla if you will um notebook that
we're seeing and um we are going to be
building a uh dashboard where we're sort
of like tracking snowfall um and the
French elps and um so I have some code
here that creates a uh sort of a plot
for snow fall um over time about 15 days
prior to yesterday and 15 days of
forecast and basically here is sort of
the rendered output for this nothing
fancy going on here it's a very sort of
like plain markdown uh plain python
notebook and then we're rendering it and
we can see the uh plot at the bottom now
what are some things that we can do to
enhance this document with quto I can
add a y
so here I've added a title um and I've
also added some things like I want to
change the theme to one of the boots
Swatch themes so it's going to have that
minty green color to it and I want to
change the highlighting style of my uh
code cells as well so the output looks
now like this so we are seeing the same
content um but as we can see the sort of
the the look has changed a little bit
with just a couple uh uh um updates to
the um this yaml that we've added the
front matter that we've added on top of
the file and going from the um source
code to the output we're just running
quto render to get from point A to point
B uh we can do more things here I have
done some um more I've added more
options to the front matter that allow
me to sort of like handle how code cells
are operating so by default my code
cells are going to be folded and I'll
have a toolbar that I can use to um um
sort of manipulate or uh Express
preferences on whether I want them
folded or not and as you can see also at
the very bottom here where I was
creating a figure I've added a label to
my figure that I could use for cross
referencing later on and I've also added
a caption to my figure as well so this
is now what the output looks like again
simply running quto render obvious see a
very bare document so far just a title
we could we have some sort of data
processing code that we perhaps even
want to hide away entirely here but then
we can see that we have our um
outputting plot this is that uh the
handy code tools um um sort of widgets
that we have asked uh in the front
matter and as you can see now my figures
are being counted automatically for me
and I have a caption that I can give
them as well
um we can make other changes more
structural changes to the yaml and for
example Express that we want a different
output format this could be PDF this
could be a presentation format so here
I'm going to demo um using the same
input file so nothing has changed in the
document itself but I am outputting to a
reveal.js presentation and here is what
the slide deck would then look like you
can see that my second level headings
have now become um slide titles and
everything else about my plot is exactly
the
same all right so what does the uh
workflow for building um dashboards with
Corto look like um or building really or
creating anything with Corto uh starting
with an iy IPython notebook look like we
said that the comment that we comment
that we want to run is Corto render so
each of the CTO um commands um start
with quto and we can run these in the
terminal so with the render command by
default I will be writing to HTML but I
can choose to write to say um doc X so
Word files as well I can also do a live
preview which will allow me to every
time I save my notebook allow me to view
the output um um sort of like almost
instantaneously obviously the delay
there will depend on how much compute is
having to be redone perhaps uh in your
document but if you're executing your c
as you go along and you're just making
some changes to the markdown text or the
styling of your document that should be
almost in instantaneous and again we can
do this with an outputting to just HTML
by default or other formats like docx or
PDF um you'll also see that uh in
addition to starting with an IP INB I
can also start with a quto markdown
document which is in essence the same
idea of a computational notebook we have
in this uh document plain text so our
pros and computation so code cells
intersperse just like you would in a uh
IPI NB as well but it's a plain text
document which means uh which is
preferable to some uh because we are
actually able to sort of easily check it
into Version Control for example that's
probably my primary reason for choosing
to work work with uh qmd files these
plain text notebook files over ipbs and
another thing is that when you render
the full document it actually will
execute all your code cells as well so
you don't need to have ran them in a
particular order um before sort of uh
rendering the whole
document so here is what a plain text uh
notebook uh with qmd file might look
like so in this case um this is still
where I was uh outputting to a reveal Js
um file for example I have the yaml on
top where I give some metadata so in
this case the only metadata that's
visible in the output is going to be the
title but I can add standard metadata
Fields like author institution so on and
so forth and then my code cells are um
identified with these three back ticks
these fences and then in curly braces
goes the sort of the engine or the
language that I'm using so if these were
our code cells and the uh R would go
into the curly braces uh here I'm uh
adding some python code into my document
and anything that is plain text should
look familiar um just standard markdown
basically and so here for example I have
a new section with some standard
markdown um sort of header and then some
uh code at the bottom that displays some
um table uh using it tables
so how do we um some reasons as I said
for sort of choosing to work with qmd
files is that they're editable with any
text editor and there are extensions for
vs code NE ofm and emac um and there's
these quto extensions that you can use
uh that are handy for giving you some
buttons for live rendering uh and
previewing for
example really importantly I think that
cells always run in the same order and
and it integrates with Version Control
well because because it is plain text
and you can uh cach your output with
either the Jupiter cache or Corto
freezer uh where you can sort of Define
uh whether you want the computation to
rerun every time you change anything in
the file or only when you explicitly
render the file um there are lots of
pros and cons uh sort of between using
uh qmd files and ipb files and I think
most importantly um for getting started
with anything new the important thing is
that it works with what your choice
might be so if one of if you feel more
at home with one of these formats over
the other the nice thing is you can
build a quto dashboard either way most
of my examples uh sort of my syntax
examples going forward will show qmd so
that I can actually highlight the CTO
syntax a bit more easily but as I said
uh you can take that document and
there's actually a uh command quto
convert to go from a qmd file to ipnb
and vice versa so if you find a
dashboard a quarter dashboard out in the
wild that you like um and it's in qmd
format but you'd rather edit it in an
ipb you can just run Corto convert in
between and sort of that conversion is
done for you and uh you can move forward
with that so the rendering pipeline is
that if you're in sort of like notebook
workflow um there's no execution by
default you
uh the analyst is the one who is sort of
like executing the code cells explicitly
and then we start with Jupiter and
basically that same pipeline we've shown
before end up with one of these outputs
um if you are starting with a qmd what
happens first is that the code cells are
ran through Jupiter so that we end up
with that markdown document with the uh
your Pros in plain uh markdown as well
as the output um or any sort of images
and whatnot that may have been created
uh from executing the code and then the
rest of the pipeline is exactly the
same so let's take a look at some quto
dashboard so this is a dashboard that
we're going to come back to one more
time uh uh today and go a little bit
deeper into it but some things that you
can see here is that we have some value
boxes on top and each of our
visualizations are uh sort of like
highlighted in these cards and you'll be
able to see in a little bit that I'm not
licitly creating all of these cards
basically soon as I add a code cell uh
CTO dashboards will automatically create
one of those cards for me this
particular dashboard also has a sidebar
which uh can be particularly helpful for
interactive dashboards what even though
this one is not one of those um where
you could have some like uh UI elements
in there for user input um but you can
use that same layout for any sort of
text that you want to be visible across
the tabs you can see that we have
multiple tabs on top um as folks are
going through it here's another one
where we are displaying uh again value
boxes on top uh you can see one of them
is sort of highlighted in this yellow so
the color of these value boxes are
actually ones that you can uh Define
yourself um here we have some tab sets
again um another one where we are
looking at and um sort of a HTML widget
and interactive a leaflet U map and here
we have a sort of a model uh dashboard
with a standard model card and as well
as some other information about your
model and the nice thing here is that
you're not just like looking at a Json
dump but you can give some context to uh
what you're reading by easily um
embedding sort of um plain uh narrative
into your um sort of dashboard board as
well and here is one that is an
interactive dashboard this is leveraging
shiny for python uh where the user can
actually select the sort of the
different species of penguins or Islands
they want to see the distributions of
and the figures um uh interact with that
and here's another one where we're
seeing different tab sets so let's take
a look real quick at uh one of these
dashboards for one second and then uh
we'll dive back into the syntax so as
we've said some of these um elements are
sort of qu CTO specific we have callouts
that uh you can sort of expand and
collapse as I said the value boxes are
the co colors are conditional on the
value so you can see the number of days
below freezing changing based on the
forecast versus historical and you also
can embed uh easily sort of HTML widgets
whether that is a leaflet m app in this
case or an ey table um that might allow
you to easily um sort of you know uh
sort your data and provide some like
really cheap if you will and quick
interaction for your
users all
right very sorry about
that um did
I how did I do
this
okay all right um
so we've taken a look at the demo and
you can also interact with the code um
that is available on a gith har
repository as well if you like um how
did we achieve this really one change to
the notebook the format is now
dashboard um and once you've done that
uh there are many many elements that you
can add you can add navigation bar and
Pages sidebars as we said a layout that
includes rows columns and tab sets and
also your plots tables and value boxes
are represented in
cards um as I mentioned all of these
components can be authored within sort
of the uh IP andb format the customize
UI or with plain text qmd so here for
example uh we're looking at a notebook a
dashboard with a navigation bar and some
pages on top and so each first level
heading makes up a new page and and then
uh within those second level headings
divide up your um page into multiple
areas which are going to be these cards
where you can see the
visualizations uh we can have a global
sidebar um again with a first level
heading uh with a sidebar um class so
that's something that would look like
this as I said particularly handy for um
interactive dashboards um here we have a
dashboard where there on top we have a
sort of a focal chart maybe something
big that you might want to come back to
and then uh two smaller charts perhaps
that go into um go into more detail
about certain aspects of what on top so
we can customize the height of these
rows um as you can see um as we are
defining these second level headings so
here for example we have a three row
layout probably something like 20 50 30
or something like that um another one we
can also have our orientation in column
so something like this so once you
divide things into columns and as you
can see in the second column over here
we have two code cells that uh produce
charts and Corto will automatically
equally divide that area into two cards
for you if you want to play around with
the row Heights you can further go ahead
and do that but by default uh you don't
have to specify a height so here for
example we can see a three column layout
where each of the columns are divided
into different numbers of um cards based
on the computational cells in the
there we can also have tab set so this
allows us to keep something constant
perhaps in this case on top and then
switch between and that's simply by
adding a tabs set
class so here for example we're seeing
the tab sets in operation between the
different uh plots that um some of them
the analyst wants to uh you to see at
all times and some of them you can sort
of browse
between um in terms of plot PL uh plotly
is a great great choice for uh embedding
plots into uh CTO dashboards because it
will sort of resize itself really nicely
and easily without much effort from your
end um as the person creating the
dashboards and you can also have sort of
these in interactive for uh widgets if
you like uh so one example we gave was
the iPie leaflet for example and those
will also nicely resize as well and both
of them can be enhanced with sort of
like uh bringing in data that you're
already plotting to you know figure out
uh where for example the map should be
centered um for tables uh that we can
use tabulate or um my favorite it tables
one of the reasons why I like that is
that you get this like interactivity
built in without much effort so simply
by saying show me the data I get a a
search bar and I can further customize
that to see which uh layers of
interactivity I want to have
available um value boxes are defined in
as um basically these lists so we can
choose a color and we can choose a
bootstrap icon to go along with it and
in this case I'm using a function that I
may have defined earlier on uh to uh
calculate the value that should be shown
in my um in my um value box
alternatively I can pull it out of a
pre-calculated data set or something
like that so this would look something
like this and um the color uh can also
be you know customized uh you know
depending depending on the value we can
you can set it to change as
well um for text content um it's just
basically plain text so you can as soon
as you sort of add some text um it will
create a separate card for for that and
present that for you um in uh sort of
separately from any of your code cells
you can do any customization to that
text that you can do uh with sort of
plain text markdown um and as I showed
in the demo for this uh snowfall
dashboard we can leverage additional C
quto features like callouts for example
collapsible callouts that you would use
the same syntax in any other quto output
uh some in a quto dashboard as
well um by default the cards are
expandable um you can turn this Behavior
off if you want but the neat thing is
that if you're particularly struggling
with trying to get too much um into a
single page dashboard for example but
you know that perhaps some of your users
are going to want to dig deeper into
things um the expand button is Handy for
that for deployment you have a variety
of options importantly these are just
static HTML pages so they can be
deployed to any uh web server or web
hosts they can be sort of static once uh
you render it a single time uh
particularly if the underlying data is
not going to change you can run these
rendered on a schedule via Cron job for
example or you can have parameterized uh
reports where um this is true for either
static or scheduled reports where you
can change the parameters
um and that will sort of like redep uh
and when the um dashboard is redeployed
it's going to get updated and finally
interactive dashboards um to sort of
like account for for a little bit of
time for questions I won't go too far
into this Syntax for creating uh
dashboards with interactive components
but um we can um so here's one way we
can sort of do parameterization we can
Define parameters in a code cell and
then as we're rendering our dashboard we
can say this is the for example the
value for the parameter that I want to
assign and for interactive dashboards we
can leverage shiny um and you can deploy
these with or without a server so here
is for example a simple uh CTO dashboard
with shiny components we can see on the
sidebar we have some user interaction uh
affordances for user
interaction and um this sort of
dashboard can be deployed on the cloud
uh with a service um byit called shiny
apps iio or on hugging face or we have
instructions or um yeah information for
rolling your own and you can also do so
sort of on pram with a shiny server or
posit connect one of them is an open-
Source solution the other one is a
commercial solution and again you could
also roll your own there too and new uh
this year uh some exciting developments
in ter in terms of um deploying uh shiny
um without a server uh leveraging
pyodide so there is an example for this
Linked In the slides if you would like
to dig into that and the code for that
is available on a GitHub repository as
well thank you so much for listening um
the importantly I should mention that
CTO dashboards is available in CTO 1.4
pre- relase this is a pretty stable
pre-release um we expect uh this feature
along with everything all the goodies
that are upcoming in CTO 1.4 to be uh
released by February or so uh but you
can go ahead and download it um either
with Pip install or from the quto
documentation site uh the quto
documentation site has um is chalk full
of information including a Blog where we
try to keep you updated on what's going
on on um some lengthy dashboards
documentation along with a gallery for
examples and a little bit of information
um elsewhere you can find on uh shiny
for Python and finally my slides are um
linked at the bottom of this um slid so
the URL for them is at the bottom of the
slide so if you would like to interact
further with any of the dashboard
examples I've shown you all of those
have the code available on GitHub on the
dashboard gallery as well thank you and
I'd be happy to answer any
questions